- She took out her mechanical
pencil, did (clicks tongue),
and then she just went for it
and she went over and
just like stabbed me.
(intense music)
- So the other day I
was scrolling on Twitter
and I start seeing photo after photo
of these little gray
dots on people's hands
and their knees and their feet,
and even their faces.
It turned out people were sharing
these permanent marks that only come
from being stabbed with a pencil.
This was the first I ever heard of it,
but it seemed like a really common thing
based off this Twitter post.
And I have a hard time trusting
the internet in general,
but the amount of people who
were responding with oh my god,
that happened to me too,
here's a picture of it,
seemed quite substantial.
I decided to ask around
the BuzzFeed office
to see if this has
happened to anyone here.
And lo and behold,
happened to way more
people than I thought.
- I wanna say it was third grade
and I dropped a pencil.
And without looking I
went to go pick it up,
but without me knowing it had
bounced back up on the eraser.
And I kinda met it halfway
and it stabbed me in the hand.
So I did it to myself, technically.
But yeah, I went to the nurse's
office and they took it out
and it's just kinda
been with me ever since.
- I got this in elementary school
with just a regular pencil.
I'm not even sure what I was doing,
but I just remember when I stabbed myself.
- I was about 10 and I was doing homework
and I think it was very
simple math that I was doing,
but I got very annoyed.
And I was laying on the
floor doing my homework
and I threw the pencil down to my leg
and it wound up stabbing
me right in the thigh.
The mark is pretty dark
and I thought for awhile
that it was gonna move,
because the pencil really got in there
and I had to like pull it out.
I thought that maybe
part of it had broken off
and it was gonna be in my body
and float around somewhere.
But luckily it stayed there,
but it's also been like 15 years
and I don't know what to do.
- I got this in middle school
and it was a very traumatic
moment in my life.
What had happened was I
was just a little kid,
I was probably like 11 years
old minding my own business.
And the girl next to me sitting in class,
it was just middle of class mind you,
she just like turns to me
and I think I had said something
that she didn't agree with.
And she took out her mechanical
pencil, did (clicks tongue),
and she went over and
just like stabbed me.
And me being me, defended
myself and I was like oh,
hell no, that's not gonna happen.
It totally punctured my
skin and when I recoiled,
I saw that a bit of the
mechanical pencil, the lead,
had been stuck to my skin.
And then if you thought
one stab wasn't enough,
she went in for a second
time and she was successful.
- I thought it seemed crazy
that a mark from a pencil
can stick with a person for a lifetime.
But I did some research,
it turns out that there is a name
for this specific type of mark.
- I got this lovely pencil
tattoo in middle school.
I was walking through a crowded hallway
and someone stabbed me.
I don't know who it was, but
now I got this forever tattoo.
- According to Dr. Cameron Rokhsar,
associate professor of dermatology
at Mount Sinai Hospital in New York,
he told BuzzFeed News that calling it
a pencil tattoo is pretty accurate.
He even said that he was stabbed
at age eight with a pencil
and 37 years later he still has the mark.
The stabbing leaves graphite particles
in the dermis layer of the skin.
If you go to a tattoo shop
and they put ink in your skin,
that also goes into the
dermis layer as well.
- I've had this pencil mark since 2008.
I remember I was in college
and I was just talking to
the person in the library
and my friend comes up
and starts talking to me
and he was sharpening pencils. (laughs)
And I just see out of the corner of my eye
like just a pencil coming down
like this towards my hand.
My instinct was just
to move back, so I did.
And he said afterwards that he was
just pretending to poke me,
but then I actually moved
my hand into the pencil.
And the mark has been
there since for 11 years.
- [Jake] Now, according to Dr. Rokhsar,
these pencil tattoos can be
removed with laser treatment,
but they don't have to be.
- And I thought I got a little piece
of the lead stuck in there
'cause it was one of those really skinny.
And I spent like two days
trying to push out the lead,
But it didn't end up coming out.
- My pencil broke and I
reached down in my backpack
and I didn't know my pencil was facing up
and I stabbed myself with it.
And I was like, had this
little piece of lead.
I also forgot about it
and so it sealed up.
And then I think like five years later
I tried to take it out
by getting a razor blade
and try to cut it open,
but it was too deep.
And so I just kinda left
it and then there it is.
(light bright music)